China reported no new local cases
overnight for the second-straight a
second straight day some good news but
at the same time Italy has overtaken
China to have the world's highest
reported death toll from the coronavirus
more than 3,500 patients have died in
Italy and more than 41,000 are infected
MTS tie-up shows how the hospitals in
the hardest hit parts of northern Italy
are reaching a breaking point this is
the front line in Italy's battle against
the coronavirus a battle doctors say
they're losing at this point what you're
seeing here isn't even the ICU that's
already full this is the emergency room
flooded with new arrivals all gasping
for breath doctors cover patients heads
with the precious few plastic
ventilators they have but make no
mistake this is one of Europe's most
advanced hospitals and it's on its knees
just outside its doors and the Italian
military moves in under the cover of
darkness their first job to find a place
to bury the dead after Barragan a
cemetery near Milan was overwhelmed in a
rare late-night address Pope Francis
asked them faithful around the world to
pray for Italy prayers which can't be
answered for CBS this morning in Fiesta
London